we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and i
appreciate this this is a voicemail
about joe biden dropping out okay let's
listen to it first and then i'll give
you my thoughts hi this is Kathy wood
from Illinois and I'm wondering what are
our chances of getting Biden to drop out
so we can get a progressive in there
I'd like to see Biden I mean excuse me
not Biden I'd like to see Bernie Sanders
my second choice would be Elizabeth one
um they could jump right back in if your
Biden to drop out my number is six whoa
okay I don't want to put her number out
there so listen I I'm getting more and
more enquiries about the the Biden drop
out movement we've got to be realistic
okay everybody else has entered their
campaign and Biden's winning every poll
now I already saw some some people who
don't seem to understand much of what's
going on on our subreddit saying you
can't trust the polls or the polls were
wrong in 2016 polls were basically right
nationally they said Hillary would win
by three she basically won by three but
this is not my opinion of whether the
polls are accurate what I'm telling you
is look in history when people are
winning every poll and everybody else
has dropped out they don't end their
campaigns now there are people talking
about Biden's cognitive decline there
are people talking about the sexual
assault allegation against Biden by Tara
Reid from 1993 there are people just
saying you know Biden didn't actually
get all the delegates he needs yet well
but he has more than anybody else I
think if you're just waiting around
thinking Biden will quote come to his
senses and cancel his campaign while he
is winning every poll you've not paid
attention to how history works unless
Biden dies or is in a coma or something
radically new or different happens that
really torpedoes his campaign people
don't end their campaigns when they're
winning every poll he may lose to Donald
Trump in November maybe the polls are
wrong I'm not analyzing the polls I'm
merely saying
focus on this to me does not seem like a
particularly good use of time versus
lobbying Joe Biden to adopt more
progressive policies for example getting
Bernie to ask Joe I will you know be out
there with you every single day if you
can do these two things to your policy
and a noun right that seems like a much
better use of our time we have a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the tax cuts that Donald Trump
wants we will talk about a ruling that
says New York will do their Democratic
primary they were going to cancel it and
a judge said no no no you've got to do
it we will also talk about restaurant
workers being told don't wear a face
mask don't wear a face mask if you or
don't work that is the choice that in
Texas in Dallas some reopened restaurant
workers are being told all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up get instant access at join
pakman.com